Zach thanks for letting us stay here
super late really appreciate it milk no
problem I just wish I had a couch for
you guys try really weird okay yeah yeah
hey before we go to sleep um uh I just
want you guys know that I tend to sleep
talk and it's just a bunch of gibberish
none of its true so I just try to ignore
it or if it's too much just wake me up
all right okay cool all right
no part of it hey you guys are my best
friends
Oh love is that love you guys good night
hey yo Justin I need to be real with you
right now the other day you took my
cheesesteak I said it was okay but I was
lying to you dude you took that she's
thinking you just ate it right in my
face and that hurt me dawg
Oh Jess is it exactly what's up you guys
need water or something it's gonna wait
mad about the cheese stick what the
cheese stick thing you're just talking
about it right now
yeah you said you're upset he took your
cheese dip no guys I was sleep talking
doesn't mean anything it's just all fake
just go back to sleep okay okay you guys
my best friends Oh
speaking of friendship I know you want
to be more than just friends with me
Quinta I saw you eyeballing me the other
day at lunch you're checking out my
jeans it kept giving me the Uptown and I
was like dang girl right here right now
front of our work friends you can't do
this to me hey hey what's happening we
having a natural disaster no
everything's fine but do you think I'm
into you because when we went to lunch
the other day that was strictly platonic
I just yet yeah not really in into you
you know never okay take it easy guys
I'm sleep-talking I thought you guys
understood I'm just saying random things
I can't control it none of it is true I
swear okay guys we're cool yeah yeah
we're cool hmm okay you guys are my best
friends thank you for being here tonight
thanks Sam for heaven as well yeah so
we'll go to sleep yeah yo Justin I was
straight a piss when you took my cheese
stick dawg like why would you do that
in quinta I'm ready when you are let's
take the leap of faith you me I'm
talking getting married maybe go to
Cancun
hey hey hey wake up was the robbing
happen E are we being robbed you did it
again I did what you really angry at me
and are you trying to get with this
because I don't feel comfortable
sleeping on the side of the bed with you
if that's what you're trying to do what
guys I am sleep talking how many times
do I need to tell you everything you're
saying is too specific and if you have
something you need to say to us you just
need to say it guys look this is my
weird thing I accept both of you for
your weird things Justin with your weird
toe fetish and you being afraid of all
people hey I respect you guys for who
you are I just wish you would respect me
for who I am I'm sorry yeah we're so
sorry man yeah well we're best friend
Omar thank you for everything you've
done for us and you know what we can
accept it
so that's fine ty let's just get that
this is good a bit all right
all right good night tonight you have my
best friends their best friend - Quinta
here's a picture I photoshopped of you
and me on the beach Justin here's a plan
I made for me to kill you because you
took my cheesy teeth are you trying to
try to cross me you try to cross me let
me kill you and Quintin I'm just gonna
go off to our own private island and
live off that's what we're gonna do
where they go sit morning my friends are
probably making me breakfast you guys
are the best
you guys are my best friends Justin I go
to your family's house is for everybody
includes over 15 days
it's gonna be amazing